يعود تاريخ انشائه لنحو 500 عام مضت طقوس
اعاده بنائه يشارك فيها السكان لمده ثلاثه
ايام من كل عام انه جسر الانكا او جسر كيس
وشانكا الذي يقع في منطقه كوسو يعود
لحضاره الانكا وهو جسر له دلالات تراثيه
عريقه لدى هؤلاء الوسطاء الذين يستخدمون
تقنيات نسيج تقليديه بسيطه لنسجد ونصب هذا
الجسر مره اخرى يبلغ طول الجسر نحو 30
مترا وعند اعاده بناءه استخدم احفاد
الانكا نفس مواد اجدادهم التي كارو
يستخدمونها في البناء والتشييد
عمي
[موسيقى]
حضارتهم قبل خمسه قرون في امريكا الجنوبيه
وتركوا بصمه من ناحيه التاثر الثقافي
والارت الحضاري وامتدت امبراطوريتهم على
طول ساحل امريكا الجنوبيه فشملت ما يعرف
اليوم بكولومبيا والاكوادور والبيرو
والارجنتين